Film Courage: You believe most movies can
come down to three words, who wants what?
Naomi Beaty, Writer, Screenwriting Teacher and
Consultant: I think that's the basic nut of of
any movie is you have a main character who is
trying to achieve something because if you don't
have those basic elements and that's not the whole
story obviously but if you don't have those basic
elements then then really what is the story you
don't have a character to be our vehicle through
a series of events and you don't have anything
propelling them forward or driving them forward
if they're not trying to achieve something so if
we just think we have this interesting character
and all these different things happen to them and
these cool like conflict situations but we don't
actually know what does this character want is
that something that we really have to do a lot
of soul searching is this are we that character
do we have to see is this us well I do think that
characters should always be like our mirror or our
vehicle through the story but when I say who wants
what I'm actually talking about more external plot
stuff because that's what's going to give you that
that plot framework to tell your story so really
the who wants what is is figuring out what
external plot thing or what destination is your
protagonist aiming toward through this story
knowing that helps you plan the
story and write it but it also
indicating that to the audience is really helpful
because that's how we track where we are in the
story if we know what that character is trying to
achieve that gives us like a yardstick to measure
is he succeeding or is he failing is he making
progress or is he having setbacks and that's the
that's that like push-pull of like hope
and fear that we have when we're watching
the movie is we're hoping that he makes progress
and gets to his destination but we're fearing the
worst we're fearing all these obstacles are going
to derail him or end up damaging him in some way
so that's what I really mean when I when I say
who wants what we need to know who are we watching
in the story whose story is it and what are they
trying to achieve from an external plot point of
view because that gives us that spine of the story
or that through line that we're tracking over the
course of the movie what distinguishes the main
character from all other characters in a film
well the writer has decided that that's the main
character no I think that to some degree that's
that is true you decide who whose story you're
telling and then what separates that character
in the screenplay or for the audience is the focus
that you place on that character you want to tell
the story from that character's perspective
or from their point of view so that we know
who we're watching go through this set of
experiences so what separates the protagonist
from the other characters is really the focus
that you place on them and how you tell the
story through the lens of their experience does
that make sense it does I just saw a Crazy Stupid
Love oh for the first time I know it came out like
2011 or whatever did you enjoy it I did I love and
again it was one not one that I would normally
think I would love but Steve Carell he's a good
guy you want to root for him and then he meets
the dark horse who then you find out is really
not that dark once you get to know him but it
you it takes you on this this journey but a lot
of the side characters are also very complicated
and complex I actually that's a great example I
just rewatched it and I had a new appreciation for
it watching it again I remembered really liking it
and finding it funny but watching it over again
already knowing where the story was going I could
pay a little bit more attention to how it was
put together and you're like it's it's pretty
much a true like ensemble because so many side
characters get their own story lines and it it
has these intersecting storylines but I do think
Steve Carell is the protagonist in that story
even though he like in act 2 we spend a lot
of time we go away from him and shift focus
to the Ryan Gosling character so just page count
wise you might not be able to decide like who is
the main character they both get their screen
time but I think what makes Steve Carell the
character the protagonist there is that first
of all the way the story starts we get into it
through him wanting to know what his story is
and and getting on board with his experience
through the story and then he also wraps it up
in the end he's the one who learns the lesson
and brings that lesson to the group and
has his transformational experience and
and we're rooting for him I think the whole
time so sure sure but you're there are so
many because it's not just Ryan Gosling it's the
Emma Stone character it's the babysitter it's all
these different ones and they all have these
interesting plights that they're dealing with
that the Kevin Bacon character and you see all
of their why they did what they did from these
different things but you still in the end you root
for the Steve Carell or at least yeah and it's so
it does such a good job of like not making anyone
the villain as well which I thought was really fun
and and and you're you're it's a great one it
is again it's one that simple concept but then
when you take all the relationship dynamics
and all the little nuances and stuff it's
it's it's quite that one's again not probably an
easy one to write were you surprised by the the
way it all comes together I was okay I definitely
was I was too and I thought that they did such
a good job of making that feel believable
but also it it's big it's over the top and
you're like oh it's it's for humor's sake the way
things come together I don't want to spoil it sure
even though it's over a decade old but we'll
keep 30 years for spoilers yeah but it's so
entertaining the way all the story lines
intersect and you don't see it coming but
then it all makes perfect sense the way it unfolds
like that so what makes an effective protagonist
a few different things I think that primarily they
have to be able to drive the action of the plot
like you need a protagonist who can take action
who's willing to take action or at least can
be convinced to take action otherwise your plot
won't advance if he's not he or she isn't doing
something to pursue their goal and then I also
think that they're on the on the character side
of things there are certain things that we look
for in a protagonist to help us get on board with
them to help us align with them and be willing
to go through the story with them so there's the
the cliche thing and the thing that writers hate
to hear is that making your protagonist likeable
but there's some truth to that even if your
character isn't likable I think they do need to be
someone that we're willing to go along
on this journey with so they have to be
at least engaging and entertaining enough for us
to like to dislike them sure so so I think those
two they're two prongs of that question which
is like what makes an effective protagonist
plot-wise in the story it has to be someone
who can take action and who can who can do
things that move the plot forward and then on the
character development side of things it's someone
that we're willing to go along with as they go
through this story I think even Stephen King
said in on writing that he didn't really like the
character of Carrie which I actually like her but
I i think that he felt that she was compelling
enough and real enough and he saw some
similarities in his town and so to invest that
much time in a character that you don't think
is actually that likable but other people saw
there's something here and I think there's even
if you don't it's been a while since I read Carrie
but I think even if you don't like that character
even if it's not someone that you would hang
out with he does a really good job of creating
empathy for that character it's like she's in a
terrible situation she's being bullied at home
and at school and she's awkward and doesn't fit
in and that of course is going to even if we don't
like her in a traditional sense I think we feel
for her and and that's enough to get us on board
and to want to know what she's going to do next
because that's an interesting theory of wanting to
spend time with a character that we don't actually
we maybe if we met them in real life we wouldn't
actually want to sit next to them at the school
lunch table that's and I can think of plenty of
people that I wouldn't want to but would I want to
invest time in a story from that character's point
of view I guess I guess because we could try to
find something that we could somehow connect with
and that's that whole if you walk a mile in a
man's shoes you'll understand what they're going
through and even if you don't agree with them you
can empathize you can understand actually to bring
it back to Crazy Stupid Love I feel like that
was another thing that that movie did really well
even if so none of those characters are unlikable
but they did such a good job of making us
care about and empathize with Steve Carell in the
beginning so that he could then go on and become
this cad-like divorce guy so he's he becomes a
womanizer for a short time in the film and I think
that could turn a lot of people off but because
they spent time in the beginning making us
care about him and feel bad for him because his
wife asks for a divorce in a crowded restaurant
out of the blue that gets us that earns enough of
our our like love for him that we can we know why
he's doing what he's doing and we can watch him
do some not great stuff for a little while before
he he brings it back around and redeems himself
and we see a lot of what he's he's being groomed
by this other guy who he doesn't get
it even from the genes and the and
he's like turn around you have a mom but like
these are not those are not the jeans for you
yes so he reluctantly goes into that womanizer
phase he thinks wearing these tennis shoes and
he's like dad jeans are okay but because that's
not he wasn't really setting out to be that person
so I think you see that he's actually a good
guy and he's doing it out of and then when
you see the other and I hope i'm not giving
a spoiler away but the other divorced dad
in the bar sipping on the drink and he doesn't
really have much of a role but you're like oh
that's the next incarnation of him like that's
you want you want Steve Carell to avoid becoming
that guy like no matter if you don't agree with
what he's doing now you know why he's doing it
sure you feel for him you want him to not be
lonely and sad so you're willing for him to
be like you said be groomed in that direction
even if it's maybe not the greatest direction.